hello so I'm making a little Vlog for a
couple of reasons the first reason is to
thank all of you guys for all of your
participation in the Vlog University
show it's been awesome you guys have
submitted so many awesome drawings and
just I'm Blown Away you guys are so
creative and it makes me a little
jealous because
I'm not as creative but anyway another
reason for this Vlog is there's this
thing that I took part in it was called
The Influence project and right now I'm
not doing very well and it ends tomorrow
so I need your help and in return I'm
going to give away a few Vlog University
t-shirts now all you have to do is
there's a link in the description just
click on the link and then log in with
your Facebook information or I think you
can sign up normally too but the
Facebook is the easiest way and then
it's like up in the corner just click
login
so once you log in I will be able to see
a little picture that kind of pops up
under my account since you clicked on my
link and I'm going to give away a few
Vlog University t-shirts maybe I'll even
have Jenna help me pick a few people out
of the the bunch say hi Jenna
free do you wanna say hi
we're getting ready to go to dinner so
before I get into that I just want to
thank you guys for being so awesome I
can't wait for the next episode of Vlog
University and don't forget the link is
down there and I'm probably actually
going to delete this video tomorrow
um so yeah
shh don't tell anybody else it's just
our little secret
um yes and we're in New York and that
was my last thing that I want to talk
about I need to like make Post-it notes
so I can remember what I want to say
what do you guys think that we should be
doing in New York today tonight tomorrow
where should we go to dinner I come here
a lot but
I don't know let me know what you guys
think uh yeah don't forget to click the
link log in with Facebook and
get you guys some free Vlog University
t-shirts
um thank you
I'm gonna go get some dinner now
I will see you guys
later
man I'm a great Vlog this is just a
really great Vlog I think it was a good
Vlog Jonas you think it was bad
I need some coffee
bye